Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Tatiana Maslany who plays She-Hulk in the MCU,
just revealed
that Marvel has pretty much quietly canceled
the series.
She goes into a couple of details behind the scenes,
why she thinks that it got canceled.
Also, part of some of the larger changes
that Marvel made last year to
they completely overhauled,
the way that they make TV shows just in general
from the ground up,
like the way they write them, the way they film them.
some of the changes affect the movies.
But we'll explain everything
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Their next big series
they're going to have will be X-Men 97.
Cannot wait to see some more X-Men stuff
happening inside the MCU.
don't worry.
We will talk about all the X-Men stuff soon,
But if you didn't see the news this past week, Tatiana
maslany was asked recently about the future
of the She-Hulk series, and she basically said
that it was done at Marvel like it has been cooked
The Shield character will continue, like Tatiana
maslany will come back as She-Hulk in the MCU,
just not in a season two.
her biggest reason
why was apparently they went way over
the reported public budget of $225 million.
That is a lot of money for a TV show, For example,
that's almost double
the budget of something like a game of Thrones
and House of the Dragon.
Imagine making something
as big as House of the Dragon season one for like
half the price
that it costs them to make She-Hulk season one.
and remember that $225
million was the figure they reported
publicly, meaning that they went over that budget
spending even more money.
it's easy
to imagine there's an accountant somewhere at Marvel.
They just blew his top.
And Kevin Feige was like, Yes, sorry,
we can't spend that kind of money on TV series.
No go no more You have to imagine that level of money
is what they typically spend
on their really big theatrical event movies.
And they have a better system
for actually making that money back,
even though this past year that hasn't
really been working out for them, even the movies
that didn't do that well back in 2021, 2022
still made back most of their money.
But the last year that's kind of changed.
The Marvel's movie is a really good example
that like that definitely lost a ton of money.
But even with movies like that,
they still have a way to eventually,
like years later, make the money back on those movies.
It just takes a little bit longer to do that.
With TV series like She-Hulk that only lives on Disney
Plus and doesn't get sold to other TV networks.
They can't do that.
So there's basically like 225, $230 million
that they just threw away.
typically when you hear about stuff
costing them more than $200 million,
you're talking about like Spider-Man movies
when it comes to Marvel TV series.
Kevin Feige said initially when they started doing
Wandavision talking to Winter Soldier,
like way back early
era Disney Plus the initial phase for TV shows.
They wanted the budget for each of the Marvel Disney
Plus shows to be about $150 million.
That's the same budget
if it's six episodes or nine episodes like Wandavision.
if you or your friends have ever complained
about why they only do six episodes
for some series, like why
so few or why are they only doing nine episodes?
Why are episodes only 30 minutes long?
Like, why is it so short? It's all because of budget.
Then just dividing that $150 million amongst
six episodes or spreading it across nine episodes
But then apparently you get to stuff like She-Hulk
and they wind up spending way,
way more than that, which they obviously do not like.
legit made a joke about this phenomenon
during the She-Hulk finale
when she broke the fourth wall in the fifth wall
and like, literally climbed out of her show on Disney
Plus and began talking
directly to the writers and Kevin Feige in real life.
he asked her to change her form
back to human off screen
so that they could save money on the visual effects
like, No, no, no, we don't have money in the budget.
Just change off screen and then come back
and it sounds like She-Hulk was one of those shows
that Marvel greenlit
early on to make as many green puns as possible
because we're talking about Hulk's here
early on when they only cared
about boosting their subscriber numbers for Disney.
Plus, like this is very early era Disney
plus rolling out as much content as possible,
as many shows as possible.
yet to imagine Bob Chapek, Bob Iger
going to them and just saying, can you give us like
ten new Marvel shows this year
And that's why for a little while
it seemed like everybody and their sister
was getting their own Disney Plus Marvel show.
Like, if you ever wondered why
they pick certain characters to get their own shows.
This was during an early era of Disney
plus pre-pandemic
when all this stuff was getting greenlit
and they just need as many shows as possible.
any just sounds like they were way, way off on their
budget estimates for what She-Hulk was going to cost.
like, in order to bring the show in on budget,
you'd have to have a TV show where they never
change into the Hulk, would you give people
a whole other reason to get pissed off about.
one of the other biggest complaints about the She-Hulk
series was the overall questionable CG.
Like it seemed like
they need a lot more time to actually polish that,
which would have cost them way more money.
Remember, this all goes back to their original problem
of trying to get too much stuff out too quickly.
This led to a lot of quality control issues
just in general for all the TV shows.
In all the movies,
Kevin Feige only has so much time in the day
and so many movies that he can actually manage
so many TV shows that he can help manage.
he wound up having to delegate to a lot
of his lieutenants, and that just did not work out.
you might have heard recently about a bunch of people
at Marvel, like a bunch of producers
that were working on those shows
originally were actually the movie people.
And a lot of them have since been fired.
Last year.
Then Marvel essentially hit the pause button
like Kevin Feige
He was like, okay, let's slow roll on all this stuff.
Give us more time to do quality control.
that's why Deadpool three is the only traditional
MCU movie that's coming out this year.
There are a bunch of TV shows coming.
but generally, their output this year is way less
than what they had originally planned on releasing.
Like, look at this Marvel Phase five schedule.
There's a lot of stuff
that was going to be released this year
that didn't even make it to this schedule, too.
So you have to imagine that there was even more stuff
that was supposed to come out all that drama this year
with Jonathan Majors getting fired,
all of his legal issues really only affected
the plans for Avengers five and Avengers six.
It didn't cause the other movies to be delayed.
Kang wasn't in most of those in the movies
or those other TV shows.
one of the other issues
I think Marvel ran into with the She-Hulk series
just in general, is that Tatiana maslany was fantastic.
Actress Have you seen any of her other stuff?
but I think they intended the show
to be mostly for your casual fans.
And a lot of casual fans had never read a She-Hulk
comic book before and didn't know
that the character was written so comedically,
and they went into it expecting something
more like The Incredible
Hulk, like way darker, more traditional Hulk.
So when she debuted they started treating her
more like Deadpool with all the fourth wall breaking,
making fun of all the tropes in the MCU, even
using a lot of shorthand during their initial episodes
with the Mark Ruffalo Bruce Banner Hulk like see
how quickly she learns how to handle all this stuff.
Whereas it took Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner,
Hulk, many, many movies, many phases
to actually get through that stuff.
It is in a land with a lot of the fans.
The way that I think Marvel hoped it would.
I don't think any of that was Tatiana maslany fault.
I think it was all just about the material
she was given.
And when they do eventually bring the character
back in the movies, as long as they do give her
some solid material to work with, I think it will
turn a lot of people around On the character.
But at least. Right now there is no season two.
Like I said, She-Hulk will come back.
Future Hulk related Storylines.
There's a ton of Hulk story
happening in Captain America four Brave
New World, but I don't think that she's actually
going to be in that movie.
But there is a lot of Hulk related stuff
happening in the MCU the next couple of years.
Thunderbolt Ross is supposed to become a red
hulk during Captain America four.
They're bringing back
Liv Tyler's Betty Ross from the Incredible Hulk movie,
because that is MCU,
even though it was Edward Norton playing the character.
Mark Ruffalo was actually recast as MCU,
Bruce Banner, Hulk.
So he's the same Hulk as Edward Norton's
Hulk, Liv Tyler's Betty Ross was his Betty Ross
even though since Mark Ruffalo debuted in that
first Avengers movie, he hasn't spent a lot of time
referencing Betty Ross in the subsequent movies
up through Avengers Endgame and Present day.
I haven't seen any news about the Bruce Banner
Hulk in Captain America four.
But this gets back to the whole Hulk
blood plotline during the She-Hulk series.
Like we don't want somebody out there
creating a whole bunch more holds.
reportedly that Scar son of Hulk teaser at the end of
the Shield finale was actually intended to set up
the next solo Hulk movie in Marvel, still working on
getting the rights worked out with Universal.
like their lawyers are still in the middle of this
ongoing wrestling match
with each other, trying to decide
who's going to make the next Holt movie.
but apparently this storyline that they're going with
is basically going to pay off everyone's theories.
pretty much everyone in the fandom has the same theory
that Marvel will eventually do
a World War Hulk movie like an Avengers
level Hulk movie.
it would basically be Bruce Banner's Hulk versus
the rest of the MCU,
all the heroes and all the villains
the maddest you've ever seen.
The Hulk, the most powerful you've ever seen. The Hulk?
I do not think that that's going to happen,
at least for a couple more years.
Like there's still a lot of weird legal stuff going on
between Universal and Marvel behind the scenes.
But if we had any news about that,
of course I'll do videos Marvel is adapting
some of those storylines, though, from World War Hoult
Because they had the whole thunderbolt.
Ross read whole thing.
The intelligence Asia, including the leader, Modok
those characters actually
turn Thunderbolt Ross into Red Hulk after World
War Hulk.
Like as a result of that.
and if we don't see She-Hulk
in the next couple of years
in any of the other lesser movies,
I do think she will be back in Avengers five.
In Avengers six in some small way.
the like I said, one of the reasons for them
canceling the She-Hulk series
mostly budget also becomes a big issue,
bringing the character back.
Any time you bring them back,
you do spend a ton of money
to have her become She-Hulk,
That's why you don't see the Bruce Banner Hulk in
like every single TV show in every single movie
because it costs him so much money.
For those.
Are you asking if she's going to come back
during Daredevil Born again?
Like if they're going to have any more lawyer stuff
going on.
Like when she's not actual She-Hulk.
Like when she's just walking around in human form.
I don't expect that
just because she's so comedic in tone.
in the way that Charlie Cox talks
about being Daredevil on the She-Hulk series.
It was meant to be kind of a one off
kind of jokey thing, like it wasn't meant to set up
a bunch of ongoing She-Hulk crossovers
that he was going to be having in the future.
It was just meant to be that one time.
But let me know in the comments
if they do bring Tatiana maslany
She-Hulk back
where do you want to see her come back in the MCU?
we just got a brand new teaser
for The Punisher returning.
You can click here to learn all about that
and click here to learn about that
brand new Black Knight Excalibur TV show
that Marvel is working on for Kit Harington's
Black Knight, thank you so much for watching.
and I'll see you guys in the next one!